this is what happens when uh people are
guilty and they know they floor the the
laws and the rules
uh it's easy to pray that i'm not the
one but uh
the issue is here is that if you
followed these effects and he had a good
conduct
um and the principles itself and he uh
guided was for he followed the
the law he wouldn't have been in trouble
the thing is he broke the law and
he must face the music it's simple
i and broke the law where we're told for
a considerable amount of money and it
will clearly be the case that mr
bronkers is not the only one who's
willing to take tens of thousands of
dollars for the opportunity for another
individual uh to tackle big game
well it does you know the
this has not only been happening
recently this has been going on for
years for quite a few years
and
every time we try and speak to the
authorities you just get shut up
and
this is where
the issue comes out into the openness
when one makes a really bad mistake
and then uh
this is what happens and the the problem
of uh
gish being issued a license for a coat
in a certain area and gun hunt in
another area
and the manner that it was done
i mean it's it's called poaching
listening to mr bronchus again there he
he appeared to be making two points when
when quizzed inside court first that
hunting is a big part of zimbabwean
culture
but also that there is a role within
conservation for hunting itself i mean
how true is he on either of those
well you know the if there's an off take
there's uh too many misdamage in the
ecosystem
then it's up to the scientists and the
the actual people that uh
the biologists and all the people that
do the studies on that to
come forth and sort of say this is a an
issue and then sit around the table and
discuss these issues um to actually say
that it's uh benefiting a lot of people
i'd like to see it because the thing is
if it's not transparent and uh
it's not
it's not accountable you know there's a
lot of questions uh surrounding the sole
issue
so when you remind mr rodriguez there
are people operating ethically within
zimbabwe and the rest of that particular
part of the world when it comes to the
hunting of animals which you know
frankly a lot of people here in europe
are very surprised they're being
targeted at all
well it's not targeting at all you know
the thing is if the law has been broken
uh
justice must
carry
its course and that's the way it has to
be i mean you commit a crime you must
face the music and uh
you know this is the issue that law
hasn't played the game you know from an
early age i mean people
uh a lot of zimbabweans don't even know
if there's lions or not in zimbabwe and
this is uh a big issue you know the
uh there's a lot of
anahana and a lot of talking and uh you
know we want to see the results the
the problem is that these animals if
they do become extinct what happens then
indeed mr rodriguez thanks very much for
time for your time good to talk to you
again